[Music]
there was some valid learn some new
leads on property investor and I helped
a lot of other people make money in
property every single week on a
Wednesday I interview one of my success
students who are financially free by
investing in property this week we have
Donovan and Georgia thank you so much
for coming down to the show folks so you
guys I think we connected in Barcelona
yeah yes last year at June 2009 tip Toni
18 yeah okay so over a year ago now yeah
what happened well we've got that was a
great trip wasn't it Barcelona and then
we came back and did the with the
Academy for July I think it was yeah
got engaged in August you guys got
engaged and then so the property thing
didn't go as quick as what we were
initially expecting but Georgia you did
some sourcing and bits and pieces in new
when she passed through Ellis there
wasn't really a strategy knew you were
too keen so basically at this point
there so you join the Academy that
summer and you spent the first few
months getting engaged dabble in a
little bit learning strategies as people
go to university and there's been four
years studying they don't expect to get
a job until the end of the unite but
sometimes people when they go on a crash
course or whatever they want results
really really very fast and that can
happen
yeah but it's okay if it takes you a
while okay and then what happened well
we went on the crash course in January
this year yeah whether it was you and
Leslie tell ya and again the great event
we started the limited company then as
part of the instruction of the course
and sourced our first rent to rent essay
in Southampton in April and by this
point you've done all the courses gone
through all the training but you
connected with a lot of other people
that materially you've got and you've
seen people's properties you've been on
the
I suppose a couple times and now you run
okay so April tell me about it
so it's actually a friend of mine an old
employer of mine who wanted to sell his
property to put some cash back into his
own business
I've got chatting to him and struck up a
deal whereby we rented it off him to
then essai it with a view of us buying
it
purchasing it and yeah keeping it as a
service combination unit but it's a
three bit penthouse level six and seven
yeah it really nice so I'm yeah we put a
bit we obviously furnished it did a bit
of decorating of its pieces with it and
since from April till now we've had just
over thirty grounds where the bookings
one property deal like five six months
yeah so in the last five months we've
averaged three thousand two hundred net
profit per month and I know that when we
spoke Georgie you said you want to you
want to quit your corporate job yeah and
what happened recently so when we we
were so busy with the essay and it was
amazing but trying to juggle work and
the essay was proving a little bit
difficult lovely job it was crazy
so when we got married this year in
August in Crete we both can grandfather
we both sat there and we both just
talking about it and I just went I'm
leaving it as soon as I get home yeah
and that was it I didn't even go back I
just gave him my notice I'm still on
holiday and job done but most people
probably have that desire I think oh man
I wish we just quit yeah but that come
on yeah well you've been able to
actually do that and back it up
financially and I tell a secret as well
when when Donovan and you joined the
Academy Donovan was like look after
please
so bad we will put on first-class
training you guys and and everything so
that's incredible so talk to me then a
little bit about the service because
because it can be a lot of work setting
you up yeah especially if you want to
make that kind of money three thousand
pounds a month one property yeah not
putting down much so I think we put
about six and a half in yeah in terms of
yeah furniture where did that come from
from my from savings from both of us
really okay so you scraped together six
and a half grand not a lot of money no
especially when you think it's gonna
make you three grand a month which has
been which just show that you are making
yeah we had no idea what the numbers
were gonna be obviously they we sort of
see little bit of due diligence with the
with the area and what the rental
requirements or demand was on air B&B
and that sort of thing but it Sam now
we'll see out across six sites bring
brought together through a channel
manager yeah and we've got cracking
cleaning team in place now had a couple
of parties in there so it's not all it's
not all rosy people were booked one or
two people booked to stay but gone in
there and there's been 12 14 people in
there so we've had to then can you ask
them to remove yeah but we have
literally being almost 100 percent but
every single month and where is that
where is that water in Southampton Ocean
Village interesting because I know
people love messaged me and said I would
have come to the crash course but I live
in Southampton I don't think you'll work
there and you guys oh my goodness it so
does we've got amazing the Cruise Line
is a gap have the docks
we've got Mayflower theater we've got
the Egeus Bowl we've got the football
and we've had contractors come down they
were doing a week's work in ten Anton
you want someone at state it's a busy
city the the owner then 15 under quid so
you'll pay me only 15 to the pound
that's for a yeah but what's the is that
for like an apartment yes I was a three
bed three double bedroom apart penthouse
apartment sure and then your wenting out
ranges from 125 to 135 pound for one to
two people yeah and then it jumps up to
40 pound sure we can sleep up to a
adults okay
and your fall pretty much 100% at the
time yeah so if you're getting like what
like a hundred and fifty pound average
times thirty one about 4600 so I can see
why you've over the last seven months I
can see why you kept it over 30 grand
yeah and then see we've been getting a
lot of bigger bookings so up to six
eight people staying at once yeah
which has brought the numbers up see
July we took six and a half grand in
revenue incredible big we had a big big
family stay for almost a week
yeah and it just pumps it right up so
this strategy of renting an apartment
and then renting out on a baby booking
calm you guys are falling in love with
that strategy and I really feed off the
reviews we get as well for me is it's
you do all that work so I have I still
go in and clean sometimes just to keep
my hand in because I wanted it there and
it's all the little touches and the
appreciation that you get from there and
was what feeds me okay I love it
I'd love people going it was just
amazing stay house was great because I
didn't get that appreciation in my last
job what was nice job it was working for
building engines okay
and you really found it not right just a
big corporate company isn't it yeah and
what sort of it it's other really were
you on before so I took it's mostly a
small part-time as well right so you're
working hot support on yeah hours but
then the thing is now you could just say
what I'm making three grand a month out
of my apartment
I'm good now I can really happily ever
but I'm just here just been doing what
we've seen been doing locally in
Southampton we've had guys contact us
through Facebook and Instagram and
things the landlord that we've got the
HMO from he's got six or so properties
that he wants us to then look after
we've been handed we went to view a
property in the same block as ours for
another essay and it was a purple on
with purple bricks yeah just got
chatting to him as as the estate agent
effectively and again a little gem
because he's got his in touch with so
many different properties that's handed
us two more properties last night that
need that are you interested in these
yeah so good it was a good it was a good
find if you like him because its
contacts and you've got a red to hate
you know yes yeah so we did the
paperwork for that in July got the keys
on the first of September
congratulations thank you so it's a bit
of a project isn't it so it's yeah
twelve double bedrooms one single
bedroom that's it full reverb throughout
got it over five years obviously with
relevant break clauses in but yet how
much how much will that be expected to
make their month once it's all Basel
rented out and don't just it all rooms
full which it should net about 2,700
2,800 pounds a month see you guys are
really like assassins the way that you
because cuz he's easy with rents and
rents to just take anything yeah you
know because because you're desperate
for a deal and you and you guys are
first you took your time a little bit
but you picked some real cherry cherry
plantain yes I mean if you can be making
two seven a month off one property three
grand a month off one apartment you
don't need many of them to make a
massive income really absolutely
so you're on track for your target which
is how much a month
well sorry the start of this year I want
to George right at work by the time I
got married so we've done that much and
we want to scale now but scale correctly
if you like rather than just rations
yeah you know you're not your
crazy people we are quite thoughtful
yeah we do a lot of number crunching and
things like that business is a risk but
it's a calculated risk yes but we want
to we want to get up to 20 K a month net
income from anything I mean that's
whatever strategy doesn't matter what
stress out of course you know that
people in the Academy that they're doing
that and more than that but there's not
loads of people yeah
I'm making more than that in 20 most
people get like 3 5 grand and then they
just go ah yeah and then relax off the
take the foot off the accelerator all I
started going into building their
investment part yeah I take some
interested we work and Regis these
companies they're like billion-dollar
come yes
and effectively what they do is rent you
man mm-hm so there is there is billions
immense event yes some of the struggles
I think I struggled initially with time
because I was obviously doing my job and
analyse and getting married planning a
wedding we didn't just do it once
Motorola's oh she's seven okay cool
so you know she's growing up fast she's
been in the properties helping us she's
been laying floor against that old yeah
she tries to help out a minute but
there's no way yeah but yeah it's just I
think because it's so different what we
feel was so different in South Hampton
because the estate agents have sometimes
been a bit of a barrier but now we have
a reference of Ocean Village or
apartment people are interested because
they can see what we're doing and see
because Matthews were coming to us and
sort of going oh we've got this and it
it's just it's just getting that your
foot in the door
yeah cuz we had we had five knocks
didn't we we tried five properties
before we got our first one turned down
agreed in principle with the estate
agent he goes back and related to the
landlord and they don't relay it
properly or whatever we couldn't speak
to the landlord and have a one-to-one
explain what we wanted to do so we lost
our five properties didn't we five
apartments before we secured to this
first money - five there were really
close
yes makes it more painful right yeah
yeah and Allah who would have probably
quest at first you know or then it got
to the third and then have been either
done or the fear it doesn't work oh yeah
yeah I've tried it it doesn't work what
made you guys carry on so no it does
work yeah I know it does work so it's
just finding the right one one idea well
it's a numbers game so that's one yeah
so you get let down on one that's closer
to your next one yeah now we're in a
good position whereby people as you say
people handing us properties or saying
are you interested in this would you
like this have a look at this so it's
yeah we can cherry-pick and yeah but
yeah so that's our plan it's in the next
12 months scale up to 2020 K a month how
difficult was it setting up the systems
because I always find that your first
deal he's always your hardest by mile
you know not only the rejection you get
before hands because people can't see
any any previous properties but also the
system's know what to expect
yeah it's like the first thing you do
anything the first time you drive to a
new place it's very different than when
you drive to it every day I guess so
what were some of the teething problems
that you had because I know that well
because there always is teething
problems with your service department
you still with the same channel manager
yeah we are we worked out - Keith -
Keith yeah I've not acute so it so the
essays advertised out on Airbnb booking
comm Expedia well your manager is called
to keep that the platform is quite a
VEVO yes come on
oh you used a kid
I know what I see the Academy members
arguing about who is the best channel
man yes that's the property there's new
ones with Ethan I think some of the
Academy members are actually setting up
their own channel managers as well so
there's this okay the first day that we
put the property on the pricing was
right and we had loads of bookings like
surprises wrong that's terrible we
worked out it was the channel manager or
whatever happens just it didn't work
yeah we managed to sort it did you what
did you do did you live from the mall or
did you just go ahead and take the hit a
couple we have tape here yeah because
couple of weeks you just have you just
we just did it and we just thought you
know what get up you know if it is a
business though where I've said
something of agreed something and then
afterwards I thought I shouldn't have
done that
but sometimes you just go stick to I
mean it's all about lost leader yeah and
it's also about how you deal with
problems so again that would have ten
things have you done you know I've got
all these bookings this bumps up a
promise of I'm gonna pull the plug it's
it's this skill that you need to be a
property entrepreneur is really born but
it's also I thought the mindset yeah the
persistence that belief the positivity
and when a challenge comes seen it is a
lesson rather than was a setback yeah
so for that it was like yeah we'll just
get reviews from it make sure we get
them and we did here and we got super
host anything back within three months
right so that's the silver lining look
you stay for thirty quid what you best
leave a review my crash course it's free
yeah absolutely
okay cool so those are some of the
setbacks rejection to begin with yeah
bookings all going messed up how did you
feel when you realized that you were
making 3 grand a month profit net pretty
tops might be honest yeah can kind of
property really net this and yes it's
six and a half grand in but it's it's
been consistent and we have our phones
on the side and the channel manager
beeps when there's a new booking and
then we look at each other another one
but we have so many last-minute bookings
as in people booked on the day as well
so it's August and September we've had
one or two days max that one booked
yeah it's literally been back-to-back
have you finally did you find it and
nightmare with all the paperwork and the
you know checking the lease and the
contract making sure that it's all
because I know this is quite a lot of
not legislation but just making sure
you've got the right contracts all done
and just sitting there and just looking
in it and we can bounce off each other
so he'll go right you read this and I'll
read it through anything I don't
understand it's just having someone to
pass on yeah and of course you've got
everyone within the Academy that it's a
big there's a big family and there's a
lot of knowledge there yeah there's even
newbies yeah I think no disrespect newer
than us that know things that we don't
know yeah so yes so good too bad I'm
learning I'm so eager to bounce off
different people although from the
Academy members because they're so fresh
yeah like you know and that's why I do
these financial freedom challenges and
stuff sometimes to keep me fresh with
some of these strategies like went to
the register combination for instance
but it's you know things are changing
Airways are changing
an area that saturate woman it might
actually become better rules are
changing so I'm learning as well and
that's great so when you realized you're
making 3 grand a month
you're on holiday your inquiry you
decide you get a quickie job how did I
feel amazing
no I mean we're so getting married which
is amazing but I was quitting my job
when I got home the trophy so happy are
you a lot happier now than you were yes
yeah very much so I still do my day job
yeah and I'm not in this full-time
Georgia so I went for company for
payment cents merchant services you like
your job
yeah I do and you know I've always I
mean you told me job are you gonna quit
at some point or you can play why don't
I play my boy yeah yeah you know what if
you like your job
I've still got the freedom and
flexibility with it because I'm
self-employed at it so I can come and go
as I like obviously if you like your job
correctly if you hate it having the
option yes but even you don't you have
the option now five helpful yeah correct
today so you work from choice rather
than from forward site which is an
empowering way to go to work yeah so
okay next move then what Aries you
looking at stick at Southampton you're
gonna move we like some Hampton so we
would like a couple more in Southampton
won't we yeah which is already sort of
being talked about it's clearly working
that's potentially to to start next
month yeah
two more days and then just keep going
Winchester okay just that half hour
outside yeah
that's crying well I'm really really
pleased that it's worked out for you
guys and I'm done you've taken action
taking the steps what would you advise
me just someone watching this there's
thinking I want to do the same how do I
follow in the footsteps of yeah crash
course it's free and you can bounce
their knowledge you can get from from
people there is amazing but it's it
ultimately it's down to you and I is are
we gonna get off our butts and booze I
think
and the thing is people always call the
excuses like that yeah and even with the
Academy I know the crash course is free
and the Christ's course is amazing I
think you probably would agree because
people think the crash course is just
like oh we bring you to the crash course
to then just sell training getting
excited yeah
because sometimes when you have your day
to day job is it exciting not really you
go on to the crash course and you're
like oh my goodness everyone's so happy
and I'm so excited and it's amazing you
more excited when you're making money
you know and we have people coming to
the shows again and again doing deals
again and again but people will make
excuses as to why not to not to pay the
six and a half thousand pounds for the
refurb on the rent to rent you gotta put
something in to get something out it's
not financial it's still time it's still
hotels yes at the end of the day if you
want to see a result you're gonna have
to put some kind of skin in the game
absolutely and you guys have done that
and you've trusted you yourself and
you've trusted our training and I'm so
glad to see you guys so happy and thanks
so much for coming on the show now maybe
we'll do a part two next year when you
make the 20 grand a month lessons of
that but awesome thanks so much now ice
[Music]